I'm going to tell you today how the rich
and Powerful really control American
politics and it's so funny because it
sounds like a conspiracy headline the
truth about the elites controlling our
political system but that's the joke
that's what's funny about it for all of
the people looking for the conspiracies
for how American politics is controlled
oh it's a cabal of pedophiles who trade
kids and drink the blood of children in
exchange for favors maybe outside a
pizza shop I don't know or it's an elite
of Jewish men maybe with space lasers or
the voting machine people
it's out in the open it's a conspiracy
out in the open the real way that the
rich and Powerful control American
politics is publicly known and we're
going to go over it here you don't need
to look for
the hidden conspiracy let's start with
campaign financing the cost of running
for office national office in the U.S is
huge and it continues going up which
means candidates rely on donations from
corporations and wealthy people in order
to fund their campaigns on average the
candidate that raises more money wins
and the donors expect something in
return for their investment it's out in
the open it's legalized bribery when a
candidate takes money from a donor the
donor on average has influence over the
candidate doesn't mean they're meeting
in person and saying here's what I need
you to do but it exerts some influence
for sure and they can expect at least
for the candidate to listen to them to
take their concerns into account when
making policy decisions and we find it
in the facts we find there's that famous
Princeton study from a few years ago
which found the legislative desires of
the wealthy and of course corporations
are much more likely to be pursued as
legislation and made into law by our
elected officials then the concerns of
just the average person so it works it's
out in the open you don't need to search
for the secret way in which influence is
being wielded it's not just politicians
influenced by money the policy making
process itself is heavily influenced by
special interests and lobbyists which
then can come in and say focus on this
rather than that these are people who
are paid it's all legal to advocate for
certain policies on behalf of their
clients they often have access to
lawmakers that you and I don't they can
make their voices heard in ways that
average people can't and so it's another
part of the feedback loop that leads to
policies that may not be in the public
interest but they benefit the select few
that are using their money to get that
influence but that's money there's more
than just money that gives the rich and
Powerful control over American politics
they also have access to the best
strategists who can help them shape
public opinion focus group polling
market research and they can use those
strategists to influence the outcome of
Elections you and I don't have that we
can phone bank we can donate paltry sums
but we don't have access to that the
political strategists are experts at
crafting messages framing issues in ways
that are favorable to their clients and
to their their desires they've got the
data the market research to understand
what will work on voters and that's
another reason they are more likely to
succeed and then the third prong of this
is media and access to the media media
can be used in and of itself to shape
public opinion and to influence the
political discourse to include certain
topics and exclude others and of course
the money is used in order to influence
media and media plays a major role in
American politics we shouldn't we should
accurately assess what the media is and
isn't but we have no choice if we're
connected to reality to acknowledge that
media generates or wields the power to
decide what stories get covered and
which stories don't how are they
presented what's the framing can
something be inserted or excluded from
the pub public discourse which has a
dramatic impact on both elections and
also on legislation passing or not when
it comes to the wealthy and the powerful
they often get favorable coverage either
through their use of strategists and PR
people through their use of advertising
dollars and this can make it really a a
difficult thing an uphill battle
for just the average person to have
their voice heard in the same way so
it's all in the open whenever you hear a
conspiracy theory about the secret
campaign to wield influence and the
elites control you could say we the why
it's it's all happening in the open
there's no need to find the secret way
in which it's being done now to counter
that influence what can be done
everybody has to be voting as a starting
point don't throw away the one vote vote
you have we should be educated and aware
of the ways in which this is taking
place if you don't even know the
mechanisms it's going to be hard to to
fight against them and then support
candidates and policies that are number
one in the public interest but number
two would work to maybe diffuse or
reduce this disproportionate power that
the rich wealthy and corporations have
that's the way it is you don't need to
find some secrets conspiracy because
it's all happening out in the open
our sponsor real paper makes toilet
paper 100 percent from bamboo never from
trees meaning no deforestation
sustainability and climate change can be
a tricky topic for people of all ages it
can be particularly challenging to talk
about with kids and real paper recently
launched the little lemurs box a 24 pack
of their bamboo toilet paper with a
beautifully Illustrated Kids book that
tells an exciting story of
sustainability the box is designed to
spark creativity and kids create an
opportunity to talk about deforestation
plastic pollution in a way that's light
and easy and with the holidays here the
book makes a great gift for a little one
on your list real papers little lemurs
box and all of the other products are
available in Easy hassle-free
subscriptions or just simple one-time
purchases on their website all orders
are conveniently delivered to your door
with free shipping and this is the best
part 100 recyclable plastic free
packaging go to realpaper.com
lemur and sign up for a subscription
using Code Pacman at checkout to get 30
off your first order and free shipping
the link is down below